I don't have a companion
[music]
I wonder if it's like this It's the
same number of times Ah
okay okay okay okay
Then b's
name is Colorful A cat with a unique flashy color
I thought she would love it, but her belongings and hair are surprisingly chic
It seems like I'm trying to stand out the most
[music]
boo
boo h ee We got
dark
[music] no matter what [music] It's
soothing
pame Your
name flies in the air like a bee
, isn't it?
[Applause]
Darling
[Music] There was
pie with the guards
love japan
[Music]
[Applause]
Kutchi nyamuii
What is this atmosphere mn
voodoo
mn uuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuu
me
goo
oh oh oh
oh oh oh yeah